[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends welcome
to our program
i'd like to know it's a question and
answer program that we have
weekly every tuesday at 4 30 in the
afternoon
pacific standard time we're glad that
you decided to join us
and we trust that the questions we have
today and the answers will be
satisfactory
i just want to give you the address
where you can write to us
and send your questions it's tv at some
tv dot org
you can see on the screen tv at some tv
dot org
i have with me uh one of the regulars
ca murray we're so glad that he's back
from panama
and we also have with us hakim
james who is relatively new
he first preached here during the final
generation theology
symposium yes and now he's doing a
series here in our studio this week
he's from maryland and he's the director
or the president
of ultimate cry ministries yes and so
akim will
very very glad that you decided to join
us today thank you for having me
and as usual we want to begin with the
word of prayer so let's just ask our
guest
to have a word of prayer for us all
right father in heaven we thank you so
much that you have given us the
opportunity
to interact with those who may be
viewing online and who have questions
and who desire to know more of your word
we pray that you'll guide us
as we answer these questions give us
wisdom and understanding
and lord may your name be glorified in
the process in jesus christ's name we
pray
amen amen amen amen well ca i think that
somebody asked a question that they want
me to answer but
i think it would be presumptuous for me
to ask my own question
so why don't you why don't you ask the
question for me it would be
my privilege my friend and my pastor you
know
we live in the internet age and the
internet does so very very much to
we can use it to enhance the gospel we
can do other kinds of things with it but
there are times when it when it can
generate and engender just a lot of
confusion
and once something kind of gets out
there it's out there and you can't pull
it back and it's hard to change it and
you know
uh so this chaos
sort of falls into that category someone
thinks you said something that you
didn't say and then it gets put down as
you
having said it and then you get you get
chaos so let's try to work our way
through this pastor it is addressed to
you
um and it says in the comment section
there is chaos i have understood
all of of stephen's i guess that's
stephen boar's
videos have been saying that we have one
god
one father god the son
god the holy spirit for a total of three
divine persons now i'm reading this just
as she sent this
meanwhile there are people claiming that
you are preaching
a trinity as if we have one god
with three different faces
do you have a statement uh from pastor
bohr
on the godhead that i can post to show
that this is not
what your videos are saying or what your
videos are about
okay so this is a good opportunity to
set the record straight indeed as they
say from the horse's mouth
and basically this series that
the question is about i did a series
titled one plus one plus one equals one
and then another one uh the omnipresence
of god that has two parts and finally
baptism in the name
as well as will within a wheel which uh
is a study of ezekiel chapter 1 which is
a very
complex chapter and i think i made very
very clear
that i believe that the godhead has
three persons
father son and holy spirit each is a
distinct
person but they're in perfect unity
and they never disagree everything they
do
is in perfect harmony and so i don't
know where this comes from the
chaos on in the comments section where
it says that i believe
in one god with three different faces uh
you know
i i don't believe that god is one person
there was a heresy back
it's called modelism or civilianism
which taught that there's only one
person in the old testament he manifests
himself as the father
in the new testament as the son and in
the age of the holy spirit as the holy
spirit
but it's the same person and we don't
believe that we believe that there are
three distinct persons
each god and eternal and
each one has their own function so now
you have it on the record
what i believe so no reason to
misinterpret
i don't know if you guys want to add
something well
john 10 30 i and my father are one uh
ellen white tells us that uh that they
are one in purpose one
one in aim one in goal um the bible has
enough
particularly dealing with christ
without him was nothing made that was
made
we find so there are three distinct
entities each with a
particular personality uh
and and each with a different uh a
different function
yet i think i definitely in agreement
with that something that comes to mind
is deuteronomy 4
6 4. i think they call it the great
shema which is
it comes out this idea comes out of this
oneness
in in purpose in mission
and it says here in deuteronomy 6 4 hear
o israel
the lord our god is one lord
the word one there is an aspect of unity
meaning not necessarily one being
but more so united in their purpose
as it concerns the plan of salvation yes
and so
another thing you have is also i believe
it's matthew chapter 3 in jesus
baptism you have all three appearing and
so that kind of as was mentioned
destroys the idea of
modalism one god three faces
because you have all three distinctly
showing up in the passage
so yeah you know when it comes to the
story of the tower of babel
that word echad is used and it says the
people are one
yes well there were bunches of people
building a tower but
the bible says they were one in what
sense were they one well they all spoke
the same language
and we're talking not only literally but
figuratively as well
and uh and then jesus also prayed in
john 17 that he wanted all of his
disciples to be one as he and the father
are one
so he and the father are two persons but
in unity
and he wanted all of the twelve
disciples to be one in the sense of
unity amen this is alluded to in the
very first
words of the bible elohim
and elohim is a plural word is a plural
ending
so you have you have uh three
individuals involved
in the creation of of of mankind
so over and over and over and over in
the bible
you don't have just three faces three
modes uh three ideas you got three
individual entities working together for
the salvation of
mankind and how they can be eternal and
how they can be god
uh how they never had a beginning is
beyond our comprehension you know we can
kind of comprehend
uh existing uh and never having an end
but uh
never having a beginning truth you know
that kind of uh
that kind of humbles human pride yes
because we really can't understand it
amen okay so let's go to our next
question
now that people know what i really
believe uh the next question is based
on matthew 10 verse 28 and if i could
have maybe ca read that text to matthew
chapter 10
and verse 28 this is used frequently to
try and teach
that man is composed of three parts
three separable parts and that one part
can live
independently of the others and so on
the immortality of the soul so let's
read matthew 10 28
and then let's see uh what commentary we
can often
offer on this particular verse so see
you want to read that
i'm in matthew chapter 10 verse 28
reading from the new king james
and do not fear those who kill the body
but cannot kill the soul but rather
fear him who was able to destroy both
soul
and body in hell excuse me in hell
okay so how do we deal with this text it
appears to say that
you know the body can be killed but the
soul can't be killed so how do we
respond to those who
believe this way i think one of the
vital things
is that something i've seen in scripture
is that
one text must be seen in light of the
entirety of scripture
concerning whatever subject that text is
covering
and so in order to understand what what
constitutes a soul
it would then take us to to look at how
was a soul created or going back to the
book of genesis
and understanding the dynamics that
composes a soul
and so for me something that um i would
quote
is genesis chapter 2.
and in genesis chapter 2 starting
from verse 7 actually i read it from
verse 6.
it says but there went up a mist from
the earth and watered the whole face of
the ground
and the lord god formed man of the dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life
and man became a living soul
so from what we're reading here it seems
like the bible is showing us that a soul
is not necessarily an
entity that exists within us rather a
soul
is who we are and in light of a soul
being a person who we are
the question is then can a soul die and
the answer would be yes
i think it's ezekiel 18 verse 20 that
states the soul that's in it
shall die so now when we're reading
matthew 10
28 and it says and fear not them which
kill the body but are not able to kill
the soul
it's not necessarily because i think a
lot of people read the text
and they inject yeah their their
presuppositions upon it
nowhere in the text does it necessarily
say this that the soul is immortal
that's right right or conscious or
conscious
right yes so that's why i would say it's
vital to look at it in the context of
the entirety of scripture so that we
don't
bring our own presuppositions to what
we're reading well said
once uh you cannot develop a doctrinal
point
yeah on one text yeah you don't ever
want to do that because you will
you will be leaning in the wrong the
wrong the wrong direction
this is saying don't be afraid of those
who have control over your body
uh respect he who has a soul who has
control
over your body and your heavenly record
and uh all that pertains to you that's
the person that you ought to fear
that's the one that you're called uh to
respect
it's interesting to look at the parallel
passage in luke
luke chapter 12 but because really what
the text is saying is don't fear those
who are
who are able to take away your physical
life precisely yes
fear him who was ever to able to take
away your eternal life
yes and uh luke 12 5 kind of hints at
that
let's read verse 4 for the context and i
say to you my friends
do not be afraid of those who kill the
body and after that have no more that
they can do
right right wow but i will show you whom
you should fear
fear him who after he has killed
[Music]
so there's no soul that lives on after
death no it's after the person has been
killed
has power to cast into hell yes i say to
you
fear him so it's dealing with the
present life and the future life
don't fear so anyone who can take away
your present life
fear rather he who can take your present
life and can also take your future life
of course depending on your own choice
right amen these two
texts marry together perfectly
the the luke just if i can use the term
lays
on top of yes of the other so perfectly
because it
it it makes it very plain um
taking my life is a is a bad thing but
uh
taking my record uh taking away my
chance at eternity taking away my chance
to be with christ
that is to be respected and to be feared
uh so don't worry about about the person
who can just
put a gun to your head and end your life
yeah but that's you know there's
you have to respect that but that's not
the ultimate the ultimate is
is losing out on eternity yeah and
that's where you want to to place you
yeah you think for example of the
martyrs
who were slain uh in the early roman
empire and also during the
period of papal supremacy yes uh you
know the
the wicked were able to take away their
life their present physical life
but when jesus comes they're going to
have eternal life yes
you're supposed to rather fear the
person who can take away your present
physical life
as well as your eternal life so it's a
contrast between the presence and the
future
so okay well any other comments on that
particular verse
i think that's powerful because you know
luke
being the physician that he is we're
seeing like as you compare the gospels
you see this aspect of one going deeper
or adding
aspects that the other does not add and
it answers the question as a result
so praise the lord for that yeah you
know there's a parable of jesus where
the soul is used also that is what does
it profit a man
if he gains a whole world that's this
present life
but loses his soul in other words loses
eternal life
and when you read the parable that is in
connection with that becomes very
clearly that
clear that it's contrasting the present
life with the future very much so
very very soon okay the next question
this is an interesting one
uh ephesians 4 verse 30 uh if we can
maybe have a keem read that one
all right uh and then if we could have
um
uh ca read revelation chapter 7 and
verses 1 to 4
uh we'll get the verses and then we'll
make a commentary on them so
first of all ephesians 4 verse 30. okay
and then we'll have ca read so you want
to read that
okay ephesians 4 30 and grieve not the
holy spirit of god
whereby you are sealed unto the day of
redemption
okay and also read ephesians 1 being
that you're in that book
verses uh 13 and 14. all right ephesians
1 13 and 14
okay in whom ye also trusted
after that you heard the word of truth
the gospel of your salvation
in whom also after that you believed
you were sealed with the that holy
spirit of promise
which is the earnest of our inheritance
until the redemption
of the purchased possession unto the
praise
of his glory so once again the idea that
we're sealed
according to this with the holy spirit
yes and then we could add also ii
corinthians 1 21-22
where it says he who establishes us with
you in christ has anointed uh
and has anointed us as god who also has
sealed us
and given us the spirit in our hearts as
a guarantee
so basically we say we see in these
verses that
the seal is the holy spirit but
revelation chapter 7
seems to add a different nuance so let's
read revelation 7 1-4 c-8
1-4 after these things i saw four angels
standing at the four corners of the
earth
holding the four winds of the earth
that the wind should not blow on the
earth on the sea
or on any tree then i saw another angel
ascending from the east
having the seal of the living god and he
cried with a loud voice
to the four angels to whom it was
granted to
whole to whom it was granted
to harm the earth and the sea saying
do not harm the earth the sea or the
trees
till we have sealed the servants of our
god in their foreheads and verse four
and i heard the number of those who were
sealed
144 000 of all the tribes
of the children of israel were sealed
okay so we have we have reference to two
seals
one seems to indicate that the seal is
the holy spirit
the other doesn't say it's the seal of
the holy spirit how do we
relate these two seals are they the same
or is there a difference between the two
something i'm looking at here is with
ephesians 4
and also ephesians 1 is an aspect
from scripture what i'm seeing is that
it's an aspect that happens throughout
the generations
god does a work of sealing through the
holy spirit
and by the holy spirit with the holy
spirit throughout the generations those
that have been wooed to christ
and trust in him however one of the
things that we're seeing in revelation
chapter 7
is the context seems to be the end of
time
and so in light of it being the end of
time like revelation 6 17
is asking who will be able to stand in
light of this great day of god's wrath
and so god is saying now he takes an
entire chapter
to answer the question of chapter six
the last question
and in doing so he says these four wins
are not going to be released
these swarms of strife are not going to
be released until this seal of the
living god is placed
upon my people in this specific
time that it's speaking about in the
context of the end times in the context
of the end time
yes so this seems to be a special seal
that yes while it may be connected in
some way shape or form to the spirit
it is an outward sign that gives
evidence of
okay the living god acts i believe it's
acts chapter 15 and verse 14
that actually speaks about paul and
barnabas they're
they're witnessing to some people and
the people actually are going to worship
them
and as they're going to worship them
paul says don't do this
turn away from these idols to the living
god
and so the living god seems to be a term
that references
god as creator the one who created all
things the seal of that creator then
if we're talking about god creating the
seal of god's creative work
was the final day of creation the
seventh-day sabbath
so this is an outward sign in the life
that says i am worshipping the creator
because
of this inward seal that is taking place
in my life
so it seems that this sabbath here the
seal of the living god is in reference
to the sev to the fourth commandment
so basically we might say that the seal
of the holy spirit that believers
receive when they believe on jesus
and they continue to receive would be
the early reign right
and then the preparation to receive the
end time seal will be the latter reign
[Music]
and clearly in revelation chapter 7 as
you were mentioning
the purpose of this seal is to protect
god's
people from the coming cataclysms
because the chapter 6
ends with the question for the great day
of his wrath has come
and who is able to stand the very next
chapter says
those who have the seal will be
protected yes and of course this comes
from this whole scene of the ceiling on
the forehead comes from ezekiel
yes so you have to also look at ezekiel
because there the angels are told to
destroy jerusalem
everyone in it yes except for those who
sigh and cry
over the abominations that are being
committed in the city so
also in the old testament before
nebuchadnezzar comes to destroy
jerusalem
there's a ceiling of those who are not
participating in the abominations
that are being committed among god's
professed people because this is
jerusalem
so at the end of time most of the
christian world is going to be in
apostasy
and yet god is going to have a faithful
remnant yes that will receive this seal
because they've received the latter rain
and they're faithful to the lord
and they will be protected in the time
of trouble yeah
that's the way you ask the question it's
a little tricky because the ceiling is
always a settling of one's relationship
with god
throughout all history but there are
there are different
manifestations of that settling
depending on the time and the challenges
that god's people are going to have to
face
right so in these last days the
challenges are a little different
yes because we are coming down to the
end of all things
the the the the ceiling is still a
settling
of my relationship with my god but at
the end time
it is for to keep me against uh the
plagues that are going to fall
uh the havoc that the earth is going to
go through so
the ceiling back in christ time
people were and i use the term broadly
sealed
because they certified their
relationship with him
in these last days people will be sealed
but this time it's uh to keep us
until christ comes to deliver us from
the chaos and the drama and the trauma
that this world is undergoing right yeah
and of course the ceiling is very
closely related with the sabbath because
the end time
crisis there's actually two seals
there's the seal of god on the forehead
yes and it's related to the fourth
commandment in the first angel's message
yes
and then you have the mark of the beast
which is also on the forehead
and also on the right hand and so you
have these two
rival seals if you please one
is in honor of the creator and the other
is on in honor of the beast
so anyway that very good commentary on
that now let's go to our next question
we'll only have time for this one more
this question says the following
good evening pastor bohr and your team
the bible says god doesn't change
but genesis records that after god said
that man would die
immediately if he ate the fruit of
knowledge of good and evil
they would surely die but they did not
die
instantly wasn't that a change by god
wow so how do we deal with the fact that
god said the day you eat of the tree you
will surely die
but adam and eve did not die that day
so how do we resolve the semen dilemma
well the thing that comes to my mind
right away is that
the day they ate of the tree the moment
the second the industry the relationship
was broken
they stepped out from under the total
protection the total oneness that they
had with god
and when you move away from life
you're heading towards death where
whether it is enacted at that second
or acted at some time later you have
moved from life
to death and unless life comes and
seeks you you are going to die
it might be that that day the sentence
was pronounced
yes there's an interesting statement
here by ellen white
uh as to why adam and eve did not die
that particular day
yes i can see you nodding i bet you have
that quotation
you want to read it no no no i probably
have the same idea but probably not the
quote i wish i had the quote
i remember going through this nothing
we use that quote so i know i know where
you're going buddy
bible echo may 21 1800
the instant adam yielded to satan's
temptation
i can tell you have it there and did the
very thing which god
had said he should not do christ
the son of god stood between the living
and the dead
saying let the punishment fall on me
i will stand in man's place give him
another trial yes transgression placed
the whole world
under the death sentence but in heaven
there was heard a voice saying i have
found
a ransom so the reason why they didn't
die that day
it's possible that it's because the
sentence was given that day
but another possibility which is not
contradictory
is that that very day someone presented
himself as the substitute to take their
place that's right yes
i was thinking that's the exact thing i
was thinking of pastor i was like
because there immediately there was a
lamb a lamb to
to take the place and to take upon
himself the penalty the activation
of that plan of redemption and so a text
i was thinking of in connection with
that
that was from bible echo you said right
yeah bible i was thinking of um
revelation 13 8 where it states in in
there
although speaking about the beast's
power it gives us this powerful
it's like the veil is taken away and it
says and
all that dwell upon the earth shall
worship him
whose names are not written in the book
of life
of the lamb slain from the foundation
of the world so what we're seeing here
is that jesus christ
immediately as man fell there was a plan
that had remained in god's heart in the
heart of the godhead
that was now activated in order to
bring man redemption the moment that the
fall took place
yes salvation was not a change in plans
it wasn't a plan b yes it was just an
activation of a plan that existed from
eternity
yes man's sin did not take god by
surprise nope
so the fact that god put into activation
this plan i'm watching the clock
doesn't mean it changed it simply means
he shifted
and went into operation this plan
that was pre-existing yes it was there
already so it wasn't a change
it was just dealing with the situation
that god had to deal with yeah the plan
of salvation was not an afterthought no
sir
it was carefully planned out long before
sin entered the universe
anyway i think i think that pretty well
answers the question yeah man
yeah so when you when you deal with
change you didn't change it yeah you
just activate it
yes boy our time has slipped into
eternity
it is always a pleasure to be with you
we'll be back again next week you be
back with us send in your questions and
we'll do the best to answer them
from the word of god god bless you we'll
see you again soon
[Music]
you